hello everyone welcome to a brand new
episode of the witching hour a very very
special episode for a whole number of
reasons one today is Halloween so happy
Halloween everybody also right now we
are in Los Angeles and I like scary
movies we loved it so much when we were
here it was in June that we had to come
back and we had to meet the creator of I
like scary movies Maximilian Hey hi how
you doing good are you family and I are
so I'm very impressed by like we're not
even in the meat of it right now but it
looks beautiful up here thank you yeah
thank you it's a nice vibe right yep so
homey for everybody out there I mean I
would decorate my own I told you I want
to go knock over a lot of especially
from my house your house this is cool
this is a lifestyle what's left in your
house I asked the thing okay actually
fair for everybody out there who does
not know what this event is can you give
a brief explanation of what I like scary
movies yes oh I like scary movies is
sort of my love letter horror
you know it's my way of celebrating
these movies in a different way so I'm
calling it an interactive art experience
because I feel like it's all three of
those things it's interactive it's an
experience and it's all based around art
so what we're doing is we're basically
kind of you know disrupting the normal
view of horror we're giving people a
different way to access these movies in
sort of a different way that they have
before so I want to have people enjoy
the remix in some of this content as
well as go into scenes that they might
be familiar with from different movies
and then just kind of you know break the
mold of what we have come to learn from
these movies is there anywhere else that
you got even the slightest taste of what
you want people to experience here was
there some sort of event or anything you
went
that made you say I can do that and you
know I could do it to a much further
extent horror related no because I
honestly feel like there hasn't really
been anything quite like this in the
horror genre that I've at least
experienced most of what we get with
horror are classic haunts which I'm a
big fan of and I will be going to quite
a few of them yeah I have gone to quite
a few in this season but I wanted to do
it different you know because I feel
like we've grown up with a lot of these
movies and then when you have a current
movie like it you know it's brand new
yet I want to do it I want to buy people
in a different way about the journey
from ideation to creation and then
opening and how long was that how long
was the seed of an idea there for you
before you actually got going and how
did you collect all the pieces you need
for goodness yeah I mean that's gosh I
mean I wanted to do something with with
scary movies for as long as I can
remember I mean I I'm a I'm a Halloween
kid and you know we were the Halloween
house on the block you know there's
always one in a neighborhood and ours
was it and so I've always wanted to play
with these movies and so I approached
Warner Brothers I think it was in 2018
early 2018 and wanting to just kind of
see if they'd be willing you know
because they just I had just finished
doing a an all-star cast show of the
original Willy Wonka live performance at
the Hollywood Bowl and which was a dream
come true for me because I'm a big Wonka
fan and so we had Weird Al and
you know and fin wolfhard from strange
things and just having a great time and
so I made this great relationship with
Warner Brothers with global themed
entertainment and consumer products and
got to know these people really well and
and I thought this is a great
opportunity because Warner's got a
fantastic crop of horror movies and I
started digging into what was
specifically Warner and it turned out to
be some of my favorite movies so I was
like yeah this is it this is my moment
to be able to kind of pounce and see if
they'd be willing so I I kind of just
asked somebody out to lunch and said
here's one contact I've become really
close with and said would you let me
just play with these movies would you
just let me reinterpret these movies in
my way and just kind of artistically
explore them a little bit in a different
way than people had before and
shockingly
they jumped at it it's that easy well
and and it was that easy in the
beginning and then it got very difficult
and and but it was you know because
these are very beloved movies I mean
it's the shiny Soviets this is not this
is not anything that you can take too
lightly you know so we had to get like
all the concepts that I have for the
shining we had to get Kubrick's
estate to sign up which thankfully they
were had no problem whatsoever
immediately no notes no anything just
yes they even said we'd love actually to
see this happen we haven't seen it quite
interpreted this way before which felt
amazing because I was like that so it
was it was all about sort of like
getting the positioning quite right and
horror is a massive massive aspect for
for Warner Brothers and so it came at
just the right time I quickly started I
da ting on all the concepts watch the
movies unbelievably unbelievable amount
of times over and over and over again
and I had I knew them backwards and
forwards already anyway but in this kind
of different way I was watching them in
a sort of different way to sort of see
what would resonate with me and so I'm
here to tell you you watch The Shining
17 times in a row it's gonna stick with
you so you're watching these movies
through just kind of waiting for that
moment that you can recreate here well
and and just to see what would inspire
me not necessarily recreate but inspire
and try to do a different way like
things like for instance the carpet room
in the shining you know and using that
incredible carpet pattern from the
Overlook and sort of you know
reinterpreting it a little bit so I
wanted to create that room so that it
had this menacing repeating pattern that
felt like you were cut off from the
world and sort of what the family felt
being there and having it happy this
claustrophobic sort of feeling about it
when on the hedge maze in the last one
balanced thank you my favorite pictures
I got that's awesome we have it back
again for this iteration but slightly
different okay so that's one thing I
really wanted to do with this as well
and I'm sure we'll get into that a
little bit about just kind of
reinterpreting even the first show so
yeah I went on watch these movies I
would just see what sprung forward and
what spoke to me and I just didn't give
it too much thought I just
with my god and and wanted it to just be
a real big mixed bag of recreating -
reinterpreting because I also want to be
kind and respectful to these movies
because they're important you know and
they're part of our culture and I have a
lot of respect it's nice to hear that
some of the folks that were affiliated
with those movies just want to embrace
the community - and let you do your own
spin on it completely it was it's so
important to them it's so important to
me that I feel like there is so much to
say with these movies and also different
ways of exploring them it's just
exciting to feel like you're part of
them - I think that's what you I'm so
excited to explore anything that's what
you achieve so well the last time it's
like I just scroll through our our
photos out in the day like we must have
a million but that to me is one of like
just the most immersive things where you
can actually feel like you were in a
frame of that movie oh yeah we we had
great fun there that day and we had a
great we had a lot of fun exploring
Beetlejuice I mean it's one if that
movie is really close to my heart and
you don't get a chance to really enjoy a
lot of things in theologies and so we
really found with that movie in
particular that people were really
excited because you don't get a chance
to have a piece of the oh jeez really
what were the pros and cons of round 1
what were the things that you learned
that you had to apply to this the second
version that's a good question you know
when I first found the Desmond location
on Wilshire I never had that large of a
space in mind and it ended up I ended up
really embracing it at first when I
walked in that I was super daunted
because it was like 25,000 square feet
it was it was a giant city block and I
had never imagined it in that way to be
honest I imagined it more so in this way
for the second show so we're kind of
doing it in Reverse whereas the first
time around I thought of it location was
gonna be something like this a little
more intimate still big but you know
have a little bit more of a cohesive
vibe that was slightly more stretched
out and I feel like this secondary show
sort of maintains its soul now and I
think that's really important with or I
feel like it needs to have its soul it
needs to have that vibe and so that was
the biggest thing that I think I learned
from the first time around was me you
know sort of encapsulating it a little
bit more and making sure that it doesn't
lose it so well like you said you uh you
also made some tweaks this time around
yeah so for the people who like us we're
lucky enough to visit the first one what
can you sort of tease for them it's a
little different this time well the
thing you can always count on with me
has had I'm this shape-shifting
individual I can't sit still and I can't
do the same thing over and over again I
I really want this to be a mutating
ever-evolving shape-shifting show you're
never gonna see the same thing twice now
you may see the same installations but
done differently so that's one thing
we're always going to do here so some
examples of that are like you said the
hedge maze with Redrum that's in a
different setting we've actually taken
the Nightmare on Elm Street pieces and
reverse them so the Freddy glove instead
of it being in the boiler room with the
brick walls and the pipes and all that
like it was before now we have the
Freddy glove ripping through his own
sweater hmm which has really been fun so
we took all of the the Freddy sweater
pattern fabric that was in the throne
room if you remember in the first time
around and we actually applied it into
the glove room now and so he's literally
ripping through his own sweaters got a
lot of energy a lot of really cool
movement about it and then we put the
faces the moving faces in around the
glove now the throne is in the boiler
room map and so we've done some things
with we have this really cool
installation of the melted Freddy skin
with some victims coming through that
was like this really cool tactile piece
in the middle of the hallway at the old
location we actually now took that and
bust out some of the holes in the brick
in the boiler room and have that now
kind of permeating through the brick and
we have this cool toxic waste dump
of Freddy skin coming out of this drum
so we kind of we just you know the thing
is I'm more out more comfortable I am
and the more comfortable I am with the
space and the pieces and in
and I've become a little bit more just
free with it and I'm able to reinvent it
a little bit if you have to watch the
shining again 17 times you know I've
watched that movie even saw my own you
know it's like I just every single times
like I have to watch it I have to see
what it when it's on cable I have to
watch it oh I'd say you just have to so
we've done a lot of things like that it
all the it stuff has been kind of
reimagined a little bit
the fear tower that we had as a
centerpiece in there we've actually
turned it into this really cool tornado
now I wanted something with movement and
so we took one of the penny wise heads
and if you remember we had four of those
heads on the outside of the fear tower
at the old location and now we took one
and split it in half put it on an
existing i-beam that was in the space
and have this tornado now coming out of
his mouth so it looks like he's just
kind of like it's this storm because I
envisioned you know penny wise this
storm that comes through Derry and so we
want her to kind of have that as a
little call-out and then my biggest most
favorite thing that we have right now
that's the it's the most new thing right
now which is Friday the 13th so we've
got this really cool installation of
nearly 2,000 hanging crystals making a
ten-foot tall version of the jason mask
Wow which is something I really wanted
to do something with this movie that
people wouldn't expect so when you turn
the corner from Beetlejuice and you go
into Camp Crystal Lake you will turn to
the left and see this massive version of
the Jason mask made out of crystals and
then over it it's it's suspended over
this lake that is all machete blades I
can't wait to see it just like I can
kind of picture what you're saying but I
know it's like yeah it's these nerd
machete blades that are all sort of you
know fish scaled on one another that
create this really great energy flow and
we actually had somebody in today who is
very spiritual and she came in to do a
walk through today and she turned the
corner and she was really daunted but in
a positive way of all the energy that
was coming off
yeah she said there's a lot of energy
around us it's kind of and she walked up
onto the dock it's a little dock around
the lake and she walked up they're very
alike apprehensively and she's like
there's a lot of energy coming off with
this mask right now I love it speaking
of energy this place is officially
haunted
oh no joke how so I unfortunately have
not seen it the one guy who would love
to see a ghost has never seen a ghost
I've seen things happen I know but I
want to see a damn ghost so my wife
Robin is the executive producer of scary
movies she's seen it and quite a few of
the people have seen it and it's this
man and he's made himself very very
known and one story was Robin and two of
our people Mitchell and and Lissette
were in the office production office all
working silent he just kind of you know
late one night and all of a sudden they
just kind of started clutching their
chest a little bit like kind of just
feeling this weird like tightness and
they all look to each other and like do
you feel that and they were all
collectively feeling like this tension
in their chest and so Robin who's very
in tune spiritually just called out to
the ghost and said look we know you're
here we know that we want to acknowledge
that you're here with us and we
understand we're here we're all together
here it's all good and then all of a
sudden the light that the tightness Mike
did you feel anything collectively I
feel like you're more spiritual are you
with that kind of stuff kayak kinda yeah
also I'm not super interested in being
with the ghosts I'm more of an oh thank
you type yeah yeah yeah curious but
feeling up make sure your lovely but no
thank you I'm the same way I really want
to see something and I just haven't I
don't really know one guy in the office
who sees things all the time and he's no
interested I love listening to his story
yeah he's like I've had enough yeah yeah
Oh Riley really Riley's got stories for
days about like please move
being in town turning on you have to ask
Riley about his stories yeah he's got
good ghost stories careless probably
okay I think there was like a degree of
curiosity there but I feel like I'm the
only one actually itching to experience
it and just like totally blocked off
from it's okay I don't know maybe that's
the thing maybe I'm too open to it yeah
before we wind down our conversation
with you we have to ask our to go to
questions
I'll go first this time oh cool is there
any horror movie TV show booked like
anything at all that you've experienced
or watched recently that you want our
viewers to know about it could be an old
thing a new thing anything at all to
know about I don't know I mean you know
people ask me a lot oftentimes what my
favorite horror movie is and honestly my
go-to like feel good if you want to say
horror movie is the original poltergeist
that's like my good I feel good for a
movie it makes me it's it just that
whole I love I love the energy was
created in that movie and so I love that
movie that's the movie that started it
all for you that kicked off the love of
the genre well the movie that really
affected me the most as a kid that
scared the absolute [ __ ] out of me was
Exorcist I mean I think that's also a
good answer that and phantasm scared the
hell out of me when I was a kid okay
somehow my parents left me alone at
night when I was a kid watching horror
movies and I had horrific nightmares off
those - yeah so that was it that
affected me the most horror wise okay
I would definitely I would love to see a
phantasm version of my legs right that'd
be so cool
I know I know that was like perfect for
you know I know we'd do something with
that bars ever considered conjuring for
this yeah yeah sorry that just like
popped up I think no that's that's
definitely something we've talked about
yes that's just well that's a great
thing about all these scary movies is
that it's it's always you know because
the first one we had Lost Boys in it
yeah now we'd sure to change it out
forefront of the 13th so it's always
gonna be again like that sort of
shape-shifting show so we're gonna add
and subtract you know movies as we go
along and that's definitely a universe
that I would love to
like tear that well all right we got one
more question burning questions yeah
burning question do you have any pets
yeah nice can a dog let's hear about him
Ridley and macho macho which I'm not a
big cat guy but I'm a big dog guy but
this this cat it we treat him like a dog
and he acts like a dog he comes when
he's called he's those badass cat and he
actually speaks to you he's super vocal
so you feel like what's up macho yeah
ground nice he's very low if you see his
name he'll he'll respond back to you you
ask him a question responds back to you
yeah and we would have a whole
conversation much was a big dude he's a
he's a big yeah but somehow he's super
agile and his great hunter he catches
bugs like you wouldn't believe and you
give him a little bit of like you know
props for that and he's like on it and
he's yeah he's a great cat actually and
Ridley who is a Jindo like this Korean
breed curly tail big old ears
awesome awesome dog do you dress them up
for Halloween I don't trust them I'm
surprised I don't actually I feel like
so much energy probably goes into this
are you still the Halloween house I'm
not unfortunately my you know I have a
little bit of stuff at the house this
year but but really this has been my
this has been great to do it during
Halloween because it's been it's my ear
that's my time to celebrate and so I've
been able to pour all of my energy my
Halloween energy here and now hence my
house is here we got we got to explore
this this I guess the secondary house
for you we're gonna talk oh my god my
favorite horror movies and explore every
single room so maximilien thank you so
much so much kitten with us and for
having us here to be holy
congratulations thank you so that was a
lovely chat and now because it's
Halloween and because we are at I like
scary movies we're gonna give a whole
bunch of Halloween movie recommendations
that are tied to different sections of
the installation here so hmm
don't let me forget anything for our it
converse
we're each gonna pick our favorite
horror movie of 2019 then for the
shining I feel like I already said
something wrong I thought we were not
picking one but giving recommendations
then for the shining we're gonna talk
about Stephen King movies yes many of
them you get one and then fine then
then it's Friday the 13th and we're
gonna talk about some great slasher
movies and then we're gonna wind down
with something family-friendly in honor
of beetlejuice and talk about things
that older moviegoers like roca will
enjoy the little kids out there look
like I couldn't help it
he made an old joke on movie talk
earlier he was asking for it alright so
it 2099 2019 what do you get what's the
first movie that comes to your mind
crawl I knew you were gonna say that
because I have mine being shy about how
much I love that movie there's there's
no secrets
I love crawl I can't I am like I have
plans already to show it to like three
or four people cuz I just got the
blu-ray watch crawl for Halloween you
will have a great creature it's true I
feel like that's also I think it's also
a great one to watch on Halloween when
you're celebrating with a bunch of
people yeah I guess that a crowd-pleaser
communal vibe that really makes it the
perfect Halloween that should be maybe
Adam ended or have an addendum whatever
the word is I I don't have brains fine
good stuffs I'm adding things it's not
midsummer might be my favorite horror
movie of the year but it's not the one I
would recommend watch this on Halloween
I can part like a communal party movie
no it's like a 3-hour depressing breakup
movie I don't know and it's super sunny
and summaries yeah watch it on Halloween
if you want to actually isn't that
director's cut out there it is maybe it
is I want to see that I stole the
director's cut yet alright crawl is
definitely on my list as well but I
can't go through this conversation and
not name-drop the movie that's still
I think at this point in time it's still
my second favorite movie of the year and
it's us of course and the score is still
on my running playlist so it's just like
when I need a little kick in the ass all
I hear is that score and then I have to
run from the tethered person that
doesn't exist behind me but I don't
necessarily know if it's the greatest
like communal watch but I think it has
some really strong scare sequences not
in the same vein as crawl at least oh I
see it's not like very going crazy like
wild type or action but um especially
having just gone through the ice maze at
Halloween Horror Nights that to me just
feels like it's got the right vibe and I
really think any time of year is a good
time of year to watch you know pretty
much any of Jordan Peele stuff mm-hmm
and I'm sure we will have all seen many
many tethered at the Halloween party
there's gonna be tethered all the
feeling there's gonna be a lot so with
how many scissors that the office is
accumulated we could have like an epic
Collider tethered group costume
oh sure that'd be wildly disturbing I
don't want that well either watch us for
Halloween and see tethered or go to any
Halloween party and see some tethers
you're covered no matter what exactly do
you want to add in another one because I
have one on the tip of my tongue go for
it you could probably guess what it is
because it's also still in my top ten
Wow I know I know not everybody out
there liked it but you know what I did I
liked it a lot I saw it many a times I
really liked the adaptation and I think
if you want the complete horror package
you have to really good Pet Sematary
movies and great source material they're
all widely available check them out it's
probably more in the midsummer pile
where mm-hmm it's a pretty dark break
it's yeah you're not gonna walk out
feeling great unless you're feeling
great in terms of having seen a great
horror movie which remember when I was
like skipping down the street in Austin
after we saw oh yeah that was that was a
moment but uh it does share some people
up it put you in the space it did bad
kids know every maybe maybe not I think
I was just so happy for
for the directors for the cast that I
really admire and I just wanted to see a
really good interpretation of that story
and I was really impressed by how they
adapted something that I thought was
already a pretty good original movie but
they added just enough where it still
maintains like the core of the Stephen
King novel but with a little extra frill
to it mm-hmm
I will throw in Annabelle comes home
which should have come out at Halloween
time anyway because it's a perfect
Halloween movie it is everybody good
Halloween movie the upside is that now
it's available to rent the Halloween so
do that cuz it's perfect and it's even
set during the fall time that's like
someone needs to build an Annabelle
themed haunted house yes like I don't
know what the I don't know what the
restrictions are and a place like a
Halloween Horror Nights but it's just
like a maze that's the Warrens artifact
well sounds like a genius idea which you
know Universal Warner Brothers doesn't
really work and also Warner Brothers has
their their thing that I've actually
never been to yeah on the lot well I was
gonna say being where we are I wouldn't
be surprised if eventually there's a
Warren artifact room maybe I guess so
something like have you ever been to the
to the Warner Brothers one no that's one
of the few in LA that that you know her
experience box for Halloween that I've
never ticks and I really want to go in
also one more just came to mind yeah
little monsters just went up on Hulu Oh
watch that good option it's super fun
super crowd-pleasing
yeah and it's on Hulu now somehow
already amazing huh yeah there's lots of
stuff out there what do you also go over
to shudder there's a million one things
oh gosh just scroll through all right
so we've talked a little bit about 2019
horror movies via it and now we're gonna
move on over to the shining territory
and talk about Stephen King add
adaptations which I kind of cheated
already and I did it
Oh kind of yeah a little pet cemetery
and hopefully come what is it November
15th am I saying the right date Wow no
dr. sleep.i day be but I hope come
whenever dr. sleep hits theaters that
that winds up being pretty high up on my
ranked list as well hopefully yeah one
more actually I'm like thinking
okay before we go to Stephen King one
last super fun very Halloween Energy
movie escape room it's perfect for a
party I feel like it's because of it
King it was January the second weekend
in January so I can enjoy a it feels
like forever ago that also is a great
option all right no all right so do you
have a movie that comes to mind I'm so
steeped in the books right now so at
this point in time I am this close to
finishing the outsider and it's really
freaking good it's really good and I'm
pretty sure I'm gonna look it up while
we're sitting here but I'm pretty sure
there's an adaptation in the works with
a killer cast and that is a great story
with a ton of meaty roles in it and
there's I'm not gonna spoil anything for
you in case you haven't read it but for
everybody who knows the book you're
gonna know immediately who I'm thinking
of there's a recurring character from
other Stephen King novels who is one of
my favorite literary characters nice
yeah
watch that next Halloween maybe I don't
yeah I'm gonna look at how long the
adaptation takes oh it springs to mind
even where we are but particularly the
first it although I like chapter two I
think is is a really good Halloween
movie super spooky energy and you know
what the part of the fun of that one is
that it feels like a roller coaster
almost it's like very thrilling and fun
and scary so that's definitely one
obviously again The Shining I mean we're
going to be walking through the shining
yes the sharing is always a must the
shining is always a must like I I
personally watch it more in the winter
because it's so snowy but yeah so this
article according to Deadline HBO is
finding an outsider for its upcoming
king project they got a director Andrew
Bernstein I wish I could find a date on
this article before this was eight
months ago so hopefully it's well
underway and I'm pretty sure I saw some
more information on this fairly recently
but I would like to see this made
not to make my entire you know
suggestion list right now things that
are in the works but the other one that
I have my eye on right now is the long
walk which I am shocked that like
immediately after Hunger Games became a
hit I'm shocked someone didn't fast
track that it's been in the works for 30
years a long time but I'm just surprised
someone didn't press go immediately
after that became a thing probably tied
up and one of the previous adaptation
yeah
Frank Darabont trying to do it forever
there yeah there were a lot of big names
and who's the big name that they landed
is that a moose Yeti project or is it
over at all I don't know I can attempt
to light that up to go Perry I don't
know all the things you know very few
things usually I have my computer on me
and I'm really quick to do this but I
will say since Frank Darabont came up
I'm a huge huge stand for the mist so
that would be a great yeah Halloween
Stephen King wall I quite like that
movie so I love my Creature Features
I like those big monster yeah I was just
really watch another one that's a good
one to watch is that watch and read I
just finally read Cujo and then I
rewatched
Cujo after and that's another one I feel
like because I had seen Cujo the movie
first it's a really great way to go from
book to from movie to book because you
know you can't really get in the dogs
head in the movie so then it comes with
this whole extra layer in the book where
you actually are you know you're you can
get a sense of what Cujo is feeling and
struggling through and he doesn't
necessarily come off as like a bad dog
mmm-hmm I get you but alright deadly
they're very deadly but admittedly at
the very beginning when he does get bit
my heart hurt for his fault the dog that
sucks
I guess those last two now sound kind of
depressing the mist and sad dog stuff so
what's a not depressing Stephen King
recommendation
I'm not pressing signing recommendation
yes for fun Halloween partying hmm Wow
yeah well they're all very dramatic
mister creep show Oh perfect or watch
the whole series on sugar but creep show
is Halloween II haven't yet I know I
know I didn't have time to get around to
and I was a little bummed too so haven't
figured out who's directing with amlong
LACMA okay is it really I wanted to know
long oh look a Collider article oh and
it's written by Hanley foutch
nonetheless memory of it
blablabla didn't have James Vanderbilt
well that's not who I was thinking the
new incarnation of the adaptation comes
from filmmaker James Vanderbilt who
boiled scripts for everything from
zodiac to White House down interesting
how long that article though because
again it's big yeah it's too old I'm a
very long time it is one of the new
directors that's in that pool of really
hot horror names right now uh-huh
man wait wait even better tags no it's
not going to work why do I try to use
the mobile site I don't know how to stop
that now
no our mobile sites great you should
definitely use it I needed a tag though
I know and I'm always entire out oh yeah
yeah do we want to move on to our next
section yeah it was slash your section
for Friday Friday the 13th let's just go
just one out of the way first
there is no Halloween for me without
watching scream I mean really there's no
month of the year frame without watching
scream but Halloween month just gives me
even more urgency to put it in and I
can't blame I watch it 12 times a year
but I do watch it every October without
coming pretty close actually when I
think about how often I rewatched scream
and Jurassic it's just like the those go
to movies that when you're in a
bad mood like you know they're gonna
make you feel better or you'll lose
yourself for a little while
Grosse Pointe blank okay we all have our
own list
yeah but rewatching scream is a priority
and also admittedly I still have my my
scream soundtrack CD and yeah that gets
that gets played every once in a while
you were right it's Andre over though
everyone's making faces in this room
baby I was on the right path
you were you were Andre over doll but
he's me Andre over doll is making his
Dracula boat movie first yes Dracula
boat what's what's your a slasher of
choice right now
well scream is definitely the like the
first one I always watch at the top of
October and track this year I didn't
even wait that long I watched it on like
September 12 I was in it to win it okay
and I watched all four and it was
wonderful oh did you really actually so
happen it was so good I can't recommend
two and four enough as well I really
think they're both excellent soda
bottles but okay I will never say no to
three though oh I will most years but it
was a fun rewatch I don't need to see it
again it pales in comparison but I think
three is just you know it it's silly
stupid yeah no I enjoyed it but I
definitely like I will watch to almost
every time I watch one that is not true
of three okay that's not entirely true
of me just because I'll rewatch one over
and over and over again but I will never
say no to it's it's it's perfect there
are those out there who claim it's
better than the first I can't party with
no but it's very good I mean I'm you're
like just to get this out of the way it
must be said Halloween of course
take your pick yeah watch a Halloween
movie for me it's the original h2o
those are my go-to s I'm a child of the
90s would have been an off like an
offbeat slasher movie or an unexpected
one the first thing that just came to my
mind is a good recommendation is
especially given the fact that we're in
the Friday the 13th section is
the final girls that's the exact same
one I was gonna say so that hands down
is one of my favorite South by Southwest
premiere experiences ever I just thought
the whole thing was so clever
immediately fell in love with those
characters like it's fun it's
suspenseful it plays with the genre so
well I really I can't recommend that
movie and up and that's another one that
really suits the whole Halloween
communal have some fun with your friends
and mine I love that movie so much it's
one of my favorites it's one I think
that actually use earns the overused
term underrated yeah it has not talked
about enough I love that along the same
lines since we're very very in a meta
space right now between scream and the
final girl it's true
behind the mask the rise of Leslie
Vernon is another excellent might be on
shudder because I feel like I almost
rewatched this recently and I think it
was because I was I was wrong Amazon - I
think I was scrolling through the
shutter scrolling through the shutter
menu that's a good one I love that movie
they made comic book follow ups to it
they really yeah and they're good cause
you would make a sequel to that there's
long talk about sigh but they did make
the comics finally which was a nice
continuation yeah
there's no moving on from this section
without I mean we've already we've
already name-drop Halloween which is
super important but the other thing that
especially Halloween time that I would
put on that exact same level as
trick-or-treat oh that's like another
one where there's no Halloween
celebration without watching you know
Sam's adventures throughout the night
absolutely that is save for proper
October 31st pretty much every yeah
that's when I watch it I don't save it
because I watch it often but it's like a
must watch on the 31st I will guarantee
you that when I hop on that plane
tonight and I'm flying home to New York
I will be watching that on my iPad
because I will not let the holiday pass
without a viewing but I really miss the
days of fEARnet when it had the 24 hour
fun of it did you ever watch that I was
like one of my favorite days ever yeah
that in the AMC marathon used to be more
beefed up you know it lasted I feel like
it lasted more had better movies look
guys the streaming wars are not good for
any of us the rights problems have
become a situation yeah I've been trying
to do you know like all the best
Halloween movies you can watch on
Netflix or Hulu and it used to be that
there were a lot of great Halloween
classics now everyone's taking them for
their own streaming services
it is churches a bummer but true and
then I thought about the rights issues
for the eighties movies that is upon us
and then then we'll lead into the 90s oh
no no no I'm on the witching hour well
we must say again tied to the location
but Nightmare on Elm Street any of them
I like them all yeah and the bad ones I
manage them that's another thing that
suits the great for Halloween yeah
threatened watching I'm feeling - the
remake which oh no you're right not I
don't believe me watch that really big
no really ever no no no I had to rewatch
that for the ranking I did for the
website and what it's that that wasn't
yeah I think I've seen it I saw it twice
you know when it came out and then I
think I saw it for like a DVD release
type thing and I just said to myself
never again it well like the it's like
that Texas Chainsaw Massacre movie with
alexandra daddario that I just sort of
watch but the only scene that I still
watch over and over whenever I need a
laugh is watching her trip over nothing
twice hehehe I found that very funny I
would rather watch that in which she is
I believe supposed to be like 42 years
old the fact that happen that movie
makes no sense
sounds may beautifully the same I'll
just pass on watching either of them and
if it's comparable or it's probably not
comparable but I'll watch screen three
over and over instead I would say if
you're gonna go for like it's not the
right holiday but the My Bloody
Valentine remake is a lot of fun and not
not at all what happened but those two
admittedly I haven't revisited it and
while but I can't remember like having
as much fun with it as most people tell
me they have
maybe it is maybe it is worth going back
to it's quite delightful man you know
what I'm those on the lines of Friday
the 13th
I'm kind of a apologist for Freddy vs.
Jason and it's perfect Halloween you
have nothing to be ashamed about I will
watch that movie anytime that and also
the the 2009 remake
I think that's an underrated remake I
don't think the thing is phenomenal but
I think there's a lot of good in it yeah
I like it a lot Freddy vs. Jason was one
of my first and worst dates really yes
that's what happened
I just know you don't cuz it's
dreadfully dull okay that's like this
wasn't a terrible date but a mishap
happened I went on a date to go see
final destination - oh yeah and there's
a snowstorm I think I've told you the
story there was a snowstorm and when I
left the theater with my date my dad was
parked outside and he wouldn't let the
date drive me home in like snowy time
and so I got in the car with my dad and
he followed my date all the way back to
his house to make sure he got home
safely proper dad's it was extremely
awkward but I am in fondly and it's one
of my favorite movies
I remember Freddy vs. Jason fondly
that's all that matters yes
forget dates movies alright last section
yeah we're in right now this is a little
something for everybody because we've
made our way over to Betelgeuse and I
think Betelgeuse is the perfect example
of a movie that is fun for the whole
family I will never forget watching both
Betelgeuse the movie but I was also very
into the cartoon as a kid I just loved
those characters and I loved the look of
it all and like its menacing but it's
also playful I feel like I just I could
recommend that again I always have to
say like I am NOT someone to ask if you
should let your kid do a thing but oh
this feels kid-friendly to me kids are
fine they can take a lot
not bad for him since my got more faith
than I did therefore I'm afraid to scar
one for life I don't know they can take
it alright if you go watch it it's like
germs it's not good to protect them too
much when they're young or they don't
build their defenses I guess I wash my
hands a lot
that's that's good it was a good habit
friendly family friendly so Coraline yes
actually I think it's really spooky it
is really spooky other mothers creepy
that would have given me nightmares as a
kid might give me a nightmare yet but
it's appropriate for children usually
what else and again I don't have kids I
have no idea what I'm talking about
oh yes hocus pocus hocus pocus is the
easiest matter that I think is totally
like I am confident in saying that's
totally safe for anybody it celebrates
the spirit of Halloween
it has delightful lead performances from
Kathy Najimy Bette Midler and Sarah
Jessica Parker and hurt just like that a
whole song and dance number gives me all
the Halloween life and also the scene
where they're just like busting down the
street while kids are trick-or-treating
all over the place I love it all of it
yeah that's all I mean really all of yes
I was gonna say something a little
goofier but a hundred percent any kid
can handle spooky buddies spooky buddies
yes it's the one where the dogs are in
calling costume I've never even watched
this oh sorry you won't watch the
buddy's films the esteemed buddies
collection space buddies super buddy now
spooky buddies my friend is this like
Air Bud yes it's a spin-off but they're
puppies instead of one spectacular dog
that I'm most afraid of our our dog
movies just because something
potentially bad other things are not
just movies are the movies where you go
oh my god there are six golden labs in a
spacesuit
that's incredible okay they're perfect
spooky buddies yeah they puppies yes
okay they are they're delicious
all right all right maybe maybe I'll
make my plate for the whole family
I'll make my plane viewing a double
feature spooky buddies and
trick-or-treat there you go okay I know
I don't know
spooky buddies I don't know who's a good
plain movie cuz it's really something
you put on the background the story's
not there but the puppies are I mean
puppies are delightful yeah I need any
setting uh this is not appropriate for
the children all the kids that listen
guys
but the buddies films are my go to
hangover movies I just throw some dogs
on
they're all cute I've never tried that
but maybe it will it will ease my
hangover the liquor I mean I feel like
this was a whole nother section of the
conversation we needed to have but it's
gonna have to wait maybe we'll make a
whole episode about that well actually
that kind of would be fun I like I
probably shouldn't put this out until
we've agreed on everybody the idea of
maybe doing you know horror friendly
mixology and then pairing that with a
like a good you know drinking and
watching experience then a good hangover
remedy after and that'd be fun okay
I'm into a cat that from the future
let's do that all right I think we got
to wind this down well we got a not
leave off the Nightmare Before Christmas
cuz it's just rude it's just rude but I
feel like I bring it up so often that I
almost felt bad like continuously say I
know and everyone knows and it's also
because like I wanted to save it a
little because I'm not gonna stop
talking about it through Christmas
that's true that's true well like The
Shining it's good for both it's true as
long as you like give me the okay to
keep talking about it I'm gonna keep
talking about many years old I am okay
alright so I hope I hope all those
recommendations keep you busy throughout
the day I hope you have a wonderful and
safe Halloween tonight and just because
Halloween is gonna be over and done with
soon does not mean your love of horror
movies needs to end we talk are on the
witching hour every week throughout the
entire year we have recommendations
non-stop and if you're in the Los
Angeles area and you like where we're
sitting right now come visit I like
scary movies because this is something
else especially if you want some cool
photo ops oh yeah your Instagram will
love this place that and if you do go
and visit the installation why don't you
tag us in it we want to see your parents
and your adventures here too
Haley where can everyone find you on the
Internet you can find me on instagram at
haystack mcgroove e and on twitter at
Haley fetch and you can find me on
twitter and instagram at PNM Rafi if you
want more information on where to find I
like scary movies we've got a link in
the collider.com article in the
description section of this video so do
check it out
that's it weird
you have officially survived the
witching hour happy Halloween
you